okay come on in okay let's go ahead and
get started I guess we can dispense with
the usual introductions which I often do
since you all know me and probably most
of you know Karen Eden we're both
faculty here when Lynn emailed us and
said there were some openings in the
schedule I generally don't like to see
that so I thought that the department
might be interested in hearing about
some work that actually a number of us
in the room I see Steve back there he
was involved in this project I don't
know a net totten I don't seeing that
anyways and then also another reason for
doing this is that we've been actually
asked to participate in a webinar from
our funder from this project so I
thought this would be a nice dry run for
the slides that we're going to present
there another nice thing about this
project is I'm always looking for
bridges across the different parts of
the department and this is a good
example that the HR q evidence-based
Practice Center is on the clinical
epidemiology side of the department but
every now and then they get asked to do
systematic reviews on informatics
related topics so it gives us an
opportunity to kind of cross across the
department so basically about points
probably about two years ago now Elaine
Graham the program manager for the
evidence-based Practice Center her
offices upstairs on the fifth floor came
to me with this RFA and said hey they
want to do a systematic review and
health information exchange so I jumped
out of my seat so it's like yeah let's
do that and we applied and we were
awarded the contract and then proceeded
into this long slog as
systematic reviews opt-in are in anyways
and then there were a few interesting
bumps along the way but we did manage to
get the program the project done we
produced the report for HR q we've
actually gotten a couple of publications
out of it even a book chapter and so
this might be a thought this might be a
good time to share with you all what we
discovered in some of the future
directions so so basically you'll see
these slides change format I'm going to
go through a few of the kind of standard
basic ohsu slide I use then we'll switch
over to HR q slides and actually will
well time ourselves because we're
supposed to do that part of it in 30
minutes or less in this webinar in about
three weeks and so and actually if it
will ask if you hold any questions that
you have we should have plenty of time
at the end to answer questions and
including people out in cyberspace who
can tweet their questions using hashtag
de maiz comp the msee conf and we'll be
able to to answer those as well this as
many of these sessions are is also
designated as a clinical informatics
grand rounds so physicians who want to
get CME credit can do so can get one
category one credit and should email
lynch mob a to fill out the appropriate
form okay I also want to tell you about
a few dates so what one it's one of
which is relevant to health information
exchange I know I've mentioned this
several times and we we changed the date
but on the evening of mei 18 Kevin
Johnson who's the chair of informatics
at Vanderbilt who produced a documentary
on health information exchange I've
actually already seen it a couple times
it's actually a really good movie he's
going to actually be here we're going to
show the MU
be the evening of the 18th down at the
CLS be invite the public there's going
to be a few other people talking about
hie then on Thursday he's going to do
Grand Rounds here do our research
conference and then also meet with
various people including at the fellows
meeting that afternoon I also wanted to
remind people everything's all set for
graduation and our usual Department
banquet will be after graduation all on
sunday june twelfth all faculty students
and staff are invited just looking out
into the future September 28 Adam Wright
who many of you know is our first PhD
graduate is winning an award I've been
sworn that I can't actually say the name
of what the award is some people know it
but Adam is going to be visiting ohsu
the first week of classes and will be
given this award when he's here and then
finally this is the 25th year of the big
building and on Friday October 28th
we're going to have a big celebration
Don Lindberg the former director of NLM
will be here some of the early people
who were here from the beginning Joe
Nash myself Paul Gorman some of the
folks from the library and so and so
there's going to be kind of a day of
activities that probably some of you
will has to be involved with but just to
note that on your calendar okay so let's
move on to the talk i'm going to give a
couple slides on that won't be part of
our HR q presentation but just in case
anyone in the audience i know everyone
should know what health information
exchanges but just in case hie I won't
read this long definition but basically
hie is the moving of clinical data
across the traditional boundaries of
healthcare organizations and businesses
so moving a patient's data from
a different from one hospital or
physician office to another from Kaiser
to ohsu or from ohsu to Providence etc
and as we'll see hie has been a little
bit more difficult than other aspects of
health information technology in part
because of this kind of business
boundary side of it so you can read this
definition which comes from the office
of the National Coordinator for health
IT website another succinct definition
I've always liked this from dr. Carolyn
Clancy who used to be the director of HR
q who describes it that basically data
follows the patient where they go to get
their care seemingly simple concept but
difficult in practice there's three main
types of hie there's a directed hie so
basically point-to-point direct sending
of data documents etc this is sometimes
called push hie because the data is
pushed from one site to another there's
also query based hie that's actually a
little more complicated because someone
does a query against typically some sort
of record locator service to find out
whether the patient has data from this
hospital that hospital some of the
original hie s like the one in Indiana
use this sort of process and people can
query to see where patient records might
exist that is sometimes called pull hie
because you're doing a query and then
you're pulling the data back to yourself
a third type of hie we don't see much of
but could in some day become the
predominant form is consumer mediated
we're basically consumers patients are
in control of their data and they decide
who to give access to and things like
Microsoft help vault and and other kinds
of collections where people control
their own data are that one of the this
kind of got to be a famous statement in
the shortly
after the ONC tried to expand up hie
that it's we should think of it as a
verb not a noun hie is the exchange of
information we shouldn't think of these
organizations even though we sometimes
use this in our language when we talk
about nhie we're talking about a kind of
organized thumb hae but ultimately
health information exchange should
permeate across the entire healthcare
system and shouldn't necessarily need to
have these hie organizations
facilitating it but obviously we're not
there yet so I'm going to I'm looking at
my watch here because I'm going to now
launched into the slides that Karen and
I are going to present when we do our
webinar for HR q in a few weeks so this
is an outline of what we're going to
talk about some of the rationale for hie
some of the past work that's been done
in terms of evaluating our focus is on
evaluating the benefits the barriers the
limitations etc of hie that's what our
report was about and that's what we're
going to talk about in the webinar we're
also going to comment on some future
directions for research so I don't know
how well you can read this but these are
just some screenshots this is our report
you can see all the other people that
took part in this it was a real large
group effort we did get a couple of
journal publications out of it we also
have a textbook chapter in a forthcoming
it should be out any day now a book on
hie that's edited by Brian Dixon of
Indiana some of you may know and then
the this full report is at the link here
and the journal articles the jmi our
medical informatics one is open access
ohsu subscribes to the International
Journal so you can get that there so
many of you have seen variations on this
slide of mine
about how you know around 2009 the
hitech act led to substantial investment
in health information technology mainly
around funding of incentives for
electronic health record adoption we've
now up to something like 30 1 billion
dollars have been allocated to health
care to hospitals to physician practices
and OHS use gotten its share of
so-called meaningful use dollars and
it's really had an impact in terms of
adoption ten years ago we used to dream
of the day that there might be more than
five or ten percent of hospitals that
use the electronic health records now
ninety-four percent actually there's a
more recent slightest of like ninety-six
percent of us hospitals have an
electronic health record system they may
not have achieved meaningful use they
may not use it all that well but they
have that we've essentially saturated
the market for physician offices were up
to about seventy eight percent emergency
departments outpatient clinics we have
achieved widespread adoption the u.s. is
no longer a laggard in electronic health
record use there's a lot of data on this
slide but the only really point that I
want to make is that the rate of usage
of health information exchange lags
behind the adoption of EHR so a lot of
people a lot of hospitals physician
practices others are using electronic
health records but the use of health
information exchange whether it is
hospitals it's it's in the 50s to 60s
percent for physician practices
depending on the specific functionality
it's in the 40s to 50s percent so there
has been less uptake of health
information exchange so HR q
commissioned this report because they as
they do in many topics mostly clinical
topics but occasionally informatics
topics like this what is the value what
is that
then show for the the value of health
information exchange and so one can
approach this just like any other
problem in in medicine we can apply the
techniques of evidence-based medicine
will see that there are some challenges
to doing to gathering evidence for the
value of health information exchange
usually you look at individual studies
when there's enough studies you do a
systematic review where you
systematically try to capture all of the
studies that have been done and then
organized them sometimes especially in
clinical topics when there's multiple
similar studies you can do a
meta-analysis can't really do that with
this kind of these kinds of studies but
we as we were awarded this contract and
we kind of focused our efforts in
looking at four areas of the
effectiveness of hie so what kind of
outcomes are seen for its benefit how
much is it used some of the slides I
showed you in the last slide how is it
implemented and how sustainable is it
and so we were funded by this contract
if you're in de maiz you probably should
know what a systematic review is but I
will review it anyways it's again
basically when you look at a given area
so that we met medicine has always had
classic Rio and many scientific fields
have had review articles where people
can review the literature but a
systematic review is really more focused
on a specific question or series of
questions and we typically involve a
librarian and go through a process of
screening thousands of abstracts to
identify the ones that meet the criteria
for inclusion some of you have heard of
the Cochrane Collaboration that's a
international collaboration that the
systematic reviews again mostly on
clinical topics important point to
remember that a systematic review is
only as good as the underlying
studies and we'll see in hie there is a
lot of mediocre studies not not in part
because it's a hard area to do a
research about but even in clinical
topic sometimes the underlying studies
are not optimal there have been other
systematic reviews there was one that
was published in 2011 and then
unfortunately there were a couple that
were done during the time that we did
ours this is always a challenge in
science if someone else is doing similar
kind of work and unfortunately these two
systematic reviews didn't really need to
follow the processes that AHRQ uses such
as involving a key informants putting
the draft of the protocol out for public
comment putting the report the draft
report itself out for public comment so
these folks were able particularly these
folks who were actually our competitors
for the contract turned around and
somehow got some other funding source
and unfortunately published in a much
more prominent journal annals of
internal medicine which publishes a lot
of AHRQ systematic reviews and so when
we went to publish our as they had
already published one and so that's why
we had to choose a different journal and
then this group also had done a was
working on a systematic review joshua
VES group some of you may know joshua so
I this slide kind of demonstrates the
literature review so we searched
multiple bibliographic databases not
only medline through PubMed but psycinfo
m-base in all the Cochrane has its own
database of systematic reviews we
identified several thousand of abstracts
and went through this review actually so
called dual review process we only
included
ones that were met our criteria and and
then we reviewed the full text of those
looking at things like whether they were
truly hie whether they were the right
study design so forth and then
ultimately slotted them into our four
categories of effectiveness for which
there were 34 use 58 usability
facilitators and barriers 32 and
implementation and sustainability 62 and
so these were out of the thousands that
we retrieve the ones that were included
in our analysis okay so then we
basically the the main investigators in
the project myself and Karen and also
Annette and the fourth main investigator
was Beth divine from the University of
Washington which is a partner in our EPC
took on different parts so I focused on
effectiveness what are these studies of
outcome actually show so we identify 34
studies that that actually investigated
some form of outcome we were hoping we
would find clinical outcomes things like
patients actually developing fewer
complications or achieving better health
but most of the outcome study focused on
what some of you know as process
measures in terms of test ordering and
things like that or on economic outcomes
how much money was spent or how much
money was safe of the 34 studies that
fit into this category 26 of them were
studies that actually measured these
things eight of them were measured what
we call perception so where they asked
people did you order do you think you
ordered fewer tests or did you think
that your patients got better care etc
unfortunately there were no studies that
actually looked at at clinical outcomes
and it's actually challenging to do
those studies because hie is not really
like a treatment you know hie is a tool
that you use to deliver care so it's
difficult to do those sorts of studies
though they could be done and in the
future research directions we'll talk
about that a little bit so what are the
areas of outcome that we found the these
numbers add up to more than the 30
whatever it was 34 because some of the
studies looked at more than one of these
but these are the kinds of things that
people looked at to see the impact of
hie laboratory testing in particular
whether it was reduced reduced duplicate
testing things like that radiology
testing hospital admissions so averting
people needed needed to be needing to be
admitted to the hospital certainly when
I did my medical training decades ago
and patients would show up in emergency
departments and their records were
nowhere to be found they would sometimes
get admitted to the hospital because
just didn't really know what was
happening what the previous diagnosis
was so could hie help with that hospital
readmissions which continues to be a big
issue patients get discharged from the
hospital and then quickly within like 30
days get readmitted costs and emergency
departments referrals in the outpatient
setting looking at measures of quality
of care public health reporting is
another topic and then there's a few
miscellaneous ones so I'm going to go
through these and pretty much at a high
level but just to kind of give you some
of the results so in terms of laboratory
testing so these are mostly things like
blood tests and so forth that get
ordered often a lot of these studies are
done in emergency departments but
elsewhere so of the six studies wed
enta fide five of them showed some
benefit for hie in reducing the overall
use of tests though the some of the
studies some of the results the impact
on cost were pretty minimal because
blood tests don't necessarily make up a
huge part of the bill in in a st.
emergency department or these five took
place in the emergency department
setting the other was in another
hospital typesetting there was also
ambulatory so outpatient setting one of
the studies actually found that there
was an increase in testing when there
was hie probably not due to the hie
itself but in that particular study
setting there there was a slight
increase in the amount of testing the
radiology testing studies were kind of
comparable seven of them showing some
amount of reduced testing in the
emergency coming from emergency
departments again in the ambulatory
setting one actually showing increase
use of testing and one decreased testing
none of these studies really looked at
the appropriateness of any of the
testing it's always a challenge when you
just look at you know how much testing
did people order it's a lot more
complicated to actually go in and try to
judge whether or not that increased or
decreased level of testing was
appropriate the presumption though is
that at least for some patients you
would identify tests that they already
have so you wouldn't need to reorder
those tests a lot of tests get reordered
in emergency departments unnecessarily
and and that would be one of the goals
for hie hospital admissions we
identified eight studies and two of them
found that having an hie capability
present resulted in reduced hospital
admissions and lower costs and another
three
found some benefit in reducing hospital
admissions although again there were
three that found no benefit whatsoever
in terms of readmissions the same sort
of thing one study showed benefit in hie
in having hie that would reduce
readmissions to the hospital but another
study showing that there were studies
that looked at cost particularly in
emergency departments and here you you
see some of the limitations of these
studies because it's challenging to
measure patient the measure a single
patient cost I mean you can look at the
bill for that patient but emergency
departments have / had patients might
get admitted to the hospital and so then
some of the costs get attributed to the
hospitalization and not the emergency
department but the two studies that
looked at this found that there were
reduce emergency department costs when a
che was present these were before and
after kind of studies actually came from
Memphis but you know what one of the
studies made a big deal about a million
dollars in savings I know a million
dollars is a lot of money but a million
dollars for an emergency department at a
large hospitals actually not a lot of
money I don't know what the budget here
for our emergency department is but I'm
sure it's on the orders of many millions
of dollars that and probably dozens of
millions of dollars tens of millions
whatever another study looked at
referrals obviously hae can potentially
be of value in facilitating referrals
from one position to another position to
a hospital whatever and again there were
kind of mixed results there there were a
couple studies that looked at or three
studies that looked at association
between the use of hie and the quality
of care quality of care in ambulatory
settings that's typically measured by
process measures so things like patients
with diabetes getting
the appropriate testing the testing
their hemoglobin a1c level I exams foot
exams etc there were studies that found
that hie was associated with improvement
in those measures of care there was
another study that looked at medication
reconciliation which is a big issue
because well if you're not familiar with
health care you might think that
patients have a single solitary list of
medications that they take but it's
actually not that simple their patients
go into the hospital their medications
get changed this patient sees a
specialist who only has a partial list
of their medications etc so there was
actually randomized control trial that
looked at this hie facilitated
medication reconciliation and found that
the the system was good at detecting
medication adherence problems but could
not actually demonstrate actually
improve adherence after it was
identified by providers so you could
identify that people were not adhering
to their medication regimens but it was
difficult to do anything about it there
were other studies that show that hie
does facilitate aspects of public health
reporting some of these I think all
these studies came from Indiana where
they've been very effective at this and
you know one of the big challenges in
public health is getting the data from
the healthcare system to the public
health system and these studies showed
that that was beneficial another study
actually wasn't from indiana i think is
louisiana showing that the hie helped
identify patients with HIV and
encouraged them to get care to get on
their medications to improve their
status and then a few other
miscellaneous studies reduction in time
one study showed the reduction in time
for fruit
disability claims another study looked
at an issue that comes up in a lot of
healthcare settings as people who are
overly frequent users of emergency
departments and you could identify that
through an hie system and then another
study looking at finding an association
not necessarily cause and effect but
with hie implementation and improved
patient satisfaction scores which are
kind of controversial area but it did
show that so I think at this point well
one more slide and then I'll turn it
over to Karen and I'm right on time so
what are some of the what can we
conclude from these studies you know
unfortunately I'm just kind of giving
you brief overview of thirty-some-odd
studies but the big challenge with these
studies is that they're retrospective
and so as you all should know
retrospective studies always have
potential confounders that may that
makes it difficult to determine cause
and effect and and looking at relatively
limited questions so for example just
looking at emergency department costs
without looking at the larger health
system and also focusing on an absolute
and relative versus absolute cost so you
might relatively decrease the cost by
twenty-five percent but if it's a small
amount of money in the larger health
system that that might not be as
important there were no patient specific
clinical outcomes that were studied and
many of these places came from so-called
hie leaders this has always been a
challenge in informatics in any area
that a lot of the research being done by
people who have homegrown systems and
that might not be generalizable to the
rest of the world so I'm going to turn
it over to karen's part and then I'll
come back at the end and then we'll both
take any questions all right so now
we're going to shift gears and we're
going to look at the evidence a
different way we're going to look at the
evidence with a focus on barriers and
facilitators
to actual hie and this is opposed to
planned or proposed exchange this is
actually used so we identified 10
cross-sectional studies seven multiple
site case studies and two before after
studies that provided evidence on
barriers and facilitators to health
information exchange and these data
sources included surveys interviews
focus group sessions observations from
292 health professionals and these were
non clinicians they might be were
affiliated with but not a clinician and
then 402 clinicians in the US we also
found additional evidence from European
studies but this was dominated by one
very large survey of 9000 over 9000
providers across 31 countries the
settings were very diverse I think bill
already mentioned that they included
exchange between emergency departments
ambulatory clinics and hospitals and so
this made it very difficult to stratify
by setting so we took a qualitative
approach content analysis and
qualitative synthesis was performed to
identify concepts for this part of the
report concepts were sorted into
groupings related to barriers and
facilitators to actual hie use two
investigators used an iterative open
coding approach to refine the groupings
and themes until consensus was achieved
and then we had a third investigator who
went through all of those and refined
further as needed we found 15 barriers
and 20 facilitators and they fell into
three very broad beans completeness of
information organization and workflow
and technology and user needs so i'll
start with completeness of information
we know that the clinicians will not
continue to exchange information if they
can't find the information
they need and so we wanted to find out
why is it that the information isn't
complete and we found there were a
variety of things that that were a
barrier one is privacy and security was
a concern expressed by providers as well
as patients liability was also expressed
by providers now these things could be
addressed with robust policy and
training so that there are ways to come
up to overcome this well some patients
may be outside of the catchment area
there was also trouble identifying
patients even within the exchange area
and there was some commentary in the
papers about using an algorithm make
matching approach as opposed to the
standard approach that's taken and
finally we found that the information
about concern about sharing information
with other health systems potentially
competitive competitor systems hospitals
was really only expressed in the US
studies we did not see that as a barrier
in the studies outside the US
so the most frequently cited barrier in
the literature was the login process if
a provider had to have multiple logins
multiple passwords this is a barrier
that was hard to overcome so the sites
that had one login process seem to have
much higher use now the probably the
most commonly cited facilitator was a
workflow that included proxy users by
proxy users I mean the admitting clerk
or the registrar or the medical
assistant would go in to the exchange
find out do an inventory what
information is available it might make a
summary sheet for the provider then the
provider could be strategic about
querying for certain information and
what also came out of this literature is
that there were really couple different
uses one use solista kindness inventory
of information but providers were using
the exchange really from for timely
decision making and we're looking for
certain key pieces once a group from the
mid-south e Health Alliance reported
that when a policy that allowed proxy
user was eliminated youth dropped so
they saw very clear barrier that went up
as soon as the proxy users were not
allowed to access the system besides
that had the most use had a couple of
strategies in place they were getting
ongoing metrics on access seeing is it
increasing is it dropping also they were
collecting ongoing feedback from users
to find out if the information was
useful and helpful moving on to our
third broad category the actual
technology and the user needs proved to
be a barrier or could be a facilitator
depending on how you approached it sites
with more complete integration meaning
information was pushed to the provider
systems naturally were used more as
opposed to requiring providers to have
to go and do an extensive amount of
querying sites that had a very complete
Hospital portal the information was very
thorough in the hospital portal that
meant the provider could go to that
portal or might not
also then seek out information in the
exchange the other thing that was in the
literature quite a bit was the actual
hie reports the reports that lacked
context related to the patient was
missing information improved a barrier
and also reports that had way too much
information proved to be a barrier as
well because of the providers wanted
more of a filter to streamline bit of
information and not just to be
overwhelmed with information and finally
there was concern in some of the studies
about the lack of data standards and hie
and more workers needed to understand
that better now this work was actually
kind of hard there were some challenges
that we had to overcome and one of them
was the changing nature of hie and
workflow locally so as an 80 will hie as
exchanging begun to to go forward there
might be some inefficiencies and
workflows that would be identified and
then the sites would work to refine that
workflow so that it was efficient to to
do the health information exchange
however the same thing can happen on the
other end in that as more and more
information was flowing then the
providers were getting way too much
information and they wanted some kind of
a streamlined effect to be able to get
more specific and filtered information
so there would be need to be some
ongoing effort to see if workflow needs
to be adjusted I think bill mentioned
there was a lack of standard hie
classification and terminology you know
things like the architecture weren't
contrite describe this the same way
function was not described the same way
so it was really hard to make summary
conclusions about a particular type of
system and finally we saw that there was
a lack of consistent or coherent
theoretical framework underlying the
implementation and also the evaluation
in fact only one study was really
transparent about the theoretical
framework that they used to evaluate the
system
so there's um there's a fair amount of
future work that we need to to move
forward with the evidence is really
inadequate to compare barriers to use by
type of function as I mentioned whether
it's query based or pull or directed or
pushed and also by architecture whether
the information is centralized or
federated understanding on the optimal
functionality of hie is challenged by
lack of consistent classification and
terminology and the changing nature of
these systems so these are some of the
things that I think could be addressed
in the future and just kind of all
actually this one this one was yours oh
yes that one was mine so while the
evidence is currently incomplete there
were several facilitators they really
centered around that that those main
themes i talked about obtaining more
complete information thoughtful
implementation and workflow and
including users and identifying key
functions in you okay and then so we in
the end you can't just sort of talk
about all these results and be some more
critical of them without having some
idea for future research needs clearly
doing research about hie is challenging
you know like I said before you know
it's not a not a treatment you know it's
not a drug that you can just you know
randomized people and blind people and
so and so forth so you can't you can
probably do classic randomized control
trials on certain aspects of it but but
you need to think about other methods
and then because it's difficult to do
things like randomized control trial
people run randomized control trials
people do these retrospective studies
which can be useful or so sometimes
retrospective or before and after but
again as is true in any type of research
when you anytime you look back with
respectively you have no ability to
control for
confounders and there's many famous
studies in informatics some of you may
remember the Hans study of CPOE about oh
it's about a decade ago now that they
made all kinds of changes one of which
happened to be CPOE and there was
actually a higher mortality rate but you
couldn't really tell whether there was
any whether the mortality rate was
connected to the CPOE because they made
so many other changes in the process so
clearly prospective evaluation is the
best approach one of the possibilities
is to even if you can't do controlled
studies you can still do prospective
observational studies where you can look
at things going forward and now that we
have these EHR systems that are
collecting data we have these some hie
implementations and so forth that might
be a possibility plus we have these
ever-growing secondary collections of
data I call out p cornet here the
peccary clinical data research Network
some of you may have heard of that are
just accumulating large amounts of data
of patients across different health
systems and so forth and of course as
Karen stated the technology's changing
and there is a lot of advocacy for even
though in some places we have pretty
good hie in other places there's no hie
actually if you do go to Kevin Johnson's
movie in May you'll see some interesting
stories it the movie is a documentary it
but there's some very moving stories
about both the benefits and also hie
implementations that were not
sustainable because part of the
challenge is how do you how do you pay
for this sort of thing when you're
basically sending your data to your
competitors in the health care
marketplace of course if you believe
conceptually that patient's own their
data and that a responsibility of a
healthcare organization is to move the
patient's data when the patient moves
then you could argue that a che is the
cost of doing business but Karen also
talked to
standards I got all excited yesterday
the article published on the preprint
and the jamia site about the smart on
fire you know which is the big new
emerging interoperability standard that
will hopefully facilitate more hie so
that's all we were going to say most of
us were funded by AHRQ because steve was
an NLM fellow we can actually claim that
that this work was supported by the NLM
training grant so we have finished that
about time and we have some time for
questions so if anyone has any questions
let us know please make sure you push
the button so people listening in
cyberspace can can hear it questions
comments oh yeah sure can you push the
button thanks so my question is actually
like for your earlier slides I'm not the
latter slice but you showed that graph
the growth of use of HR that nose to it
was a blue one and a green one and I
think the green one was non-approved or
something now the a certified recent
face well we have yeah yeah not I didn't
really go into the details on this but
these are like when they say any HR
these are people that basically just
have an EHR system their basic system
means that they actually use it for some
relatively basic functionality so this
just kind of gets to the point that we
do have a lot of adoption people aren't
you know using it for all the
functionality that they could yeah
pushing sorry my question would be also
is there any data on if there's a
adoption of the more certified from the
invasion I I don't think there is a most
of these kind of basic functions include
you know pretty
people things like the clinicians
entering orders the ability to do health
information exchange is among the
meaningful use criteria although these
graphs don't get at people who have
achieved meaningful use but that there
is that the ability to do that and one
of the many criticisms of the meaningful
use program is that there wasn't enough
emphasis in the meaningful use criteria
put on health information exchange some
people argue that that should have been
the focus rather than what proportion of
people use problem lists and
computerized order entering things like
that yeah Steve I'll just ant it so ISA
this is actually the damp sis survey so
it's a CDC survey sent out to the
ambulatory care providers and since 2014
there's a supplement to it that some
subset of those providers get and
actually asks them about further
questions including do you participate
in health information exchange so there
hasn't been a lot published on it but
there's been a few charts and tables
from the CEC about it great yeah
Catherine maybe can you push the button
yeah how do you think we can move
towards standardization of the
terminology in classification yeah great
question how can we move towards
standardization of terminology well you
know one is is that we start you know
mandating its its use like the
meaningful use criteria do problem lists
have to be in I think it's either I CD
or sno-med you know that needs to be
part of the you know the regulatory
framework but we also need to make it
easy easy to do which we haven't always
done so it's not just we need to start
telling people you know you need to use
loin for lab tests and and this and that
but but to actually make it relatively
easy to do that some of that might be
putting some of the onus on vendors so
that in order to get their systems
certified
that they are you know required to to
use those systerm analogy systems I
think I saw another yeah I was just
wondering at the other systematic
reviews looked at the same papers or
what kind of overlap there was yeah yeah
great question um somewhat the they were
they were less focused you know the the
one by Rudin and colleagues that were
was our competitors for the contract
they they they really narrowed their
scope I mean they pretty much came to
the same conclusions that you know the
the literature is challenging but they
limited their focus to the u.s. they
limited their focus to health care and
not public health so they but their
conclusions so they kind of looked at a
subset of literature that we looked at
and pretty much came the same conclusion
the the raw car I think that's how you
pronounce that person's name but their
works with Joshua vest they looked at
some different questions they tried to
look at the quality of studies and how
that impacted outcomes but pretty much
same came to the same conclusions you
know it's in all honesty it's a kind of
unsatisfying conclusion that the quality
the studies really you know don't give
you the ability to really develop a lot
of detailed conclusions but that that's
um that's basically what we found did
you looked at how the studies were
funded for each of the pigments I know
we didn't look at that I imagine that
most of studies were funded were
government funded a lot of the you know
some of the there was a fair amount some
of the high-tech about half a billion
dollars out of the 30 billion of
high-tech went to state-based health
information exchanges so States got
money and there were requirements for
evaluation and so some of those studies
came out of that I I suspect that that
probably government funding maybe some
funding to was the source but we didn't
look at that question explicitly yeah
the show this question is personally
that Karen was talking about you'd
mentioned that one of the confounders
was that that there were some providers
using a patient hospital porter portal
instead of hie I was just wondering what
that meant like what is a hospital
portal and how is that not hie or is hie
or unfortunately they didn't really give
a whole lot of detail other than because
the information was fairly complete in
the hospital system the providers were
less likely to seek it out so one sec we
have a question that came in on the
twitter feed from emily george aus key
interesting talk and hae work if
institution internal clinical
information remains fragmented and
siloed and it the the answer is that it
you know it's it makes it a lot more
more difficult you know any kind of
siloing of information you know it
really kind of gets back to the
standards if even you know we tend we
tend to talk about health healthcare
data being fragmented across
institutions but as only many of you who
work in institutions know you can have
fragmented data systems within an
institution you're your lab system
doesn't talk well to your patient
repository to your EHR and so forth so
you know I think that most of us would
would agree that the more
standardization we can achieve of data
across different information systems the
easier many things will be in healthcare
including hie so beyond ummm i'm just
going to apply to Michelle's question
you know or in Portland we don't really
have a good hie but we do have portal
access so like where I work I typically
will get a patient and I'll actually
query
three of the four hospital systems in
Portland trying to find out what's going
on with my patient which is a pain but
it also reduces them to demand it nice
for the southern hie actually the de
facto hie in Portland like in many
cities is the epic care everywhere where
you basically epic allows you I guess
they do this beyond just epic records
but you can basically bundle up data
from one epic system and move it into
another now because the it's not
standardized it doesn't populate within
the database you you get a separate tab
that has all the external data but I
know that Elise here though they get
data from a lot of patients though they
don't get everything and sometimes
there's still pieces of data missing and
so forth so yeah Erin I was just
wondering it's sort of related to this
question with the condensing of the
health systems and the condensing of the
EHRs I guess is there it was there any
discussion on the literature you looked
at at how that that angle impacts the
ability to access information or hie you
know if everybody in a region for
example is on epic is is epic is that
really a chai even though we don't we
don't designate it at it and similarly
as the health systems are condensing
here it seems like it's going to be
harder to to get any care outside the
health system and so if the hie or the
at least the access to information is
all within a certain health system
because that's all your insurance will
let you go to it is that hie and is that
going to be adequate so I just wonder if
any of the literature talked about any
of these you know the theory of hie
versus where the practical needs are and
how the changing health system is
impacting where the the need boundaries
really are yeah so I don't you know a
lot of these studies were sort of you
know this is the hie environment that we
have and
you know so this is how we studied it
but we know with all the consolidation
of Health System so EXCI one there's
another kind of terminology that we
didn't really get into but people talk
about public versus private HAES and
whereas you know private HAES are HAES
for like a health system across a region
and things like that and those are the
more growing kinds of hae these public
ones across entire states that you know
they've succeeded well in some states
you know like Indiana and New York and
others they you know they tried to do it
in Oregon and you know really what well
that there actually is one hie in
Southern Oregon that Jefferson hie that
actually facilitates a lot of hie across
of all the hospitals and physician
offices and mostly in Southwest Oregon
although they're kind of percolating up
to bend and things like that and also
the state facilitates the use of the
directed exchange but but yes no one's
really so there really isn't an answer
to your question but with the
consolidation of health care systems you
know I in some ways it might make a chai
easier because yeah I was going to say
you know the traditional hae has this
upside down economic incentive of you
know putting money into helping your
competitors do a better job but if it's
focused on these expanding and and
number decreasing health systems the
economic incentive is to do hiu within
the health system so you can you know
reduce costs and provide better care
potentially a competitive advantage so I
wonder what does you know if the
economic incentive flip will at least
make some hie more successful sure you
know as we move to more coordinated
models of care where it's actually of
value to an organization to you know in
the traditional fee-for-service system
there's X
incentive to just repeat a test because
you repeated tests you get paid for it
again but in a more of a value-based
environment like the coordinated care
organizations where you're you're sort
of getting a bundle of money to take
care of a patient with a specific
condition there's actually value in in
saving money and inpatient not getting
readmitted to the hospital and things
like that I did see one other question
from from ilya one of our fellows do you
plan to research on how hie
implementation can affect clinical
outcomes that would be a very
interesting question to research and
that would involve of course writing
grants and finding funders and things
like that but you know I think it would
be good although again there's a number
of challenges not the least of which is
the constant state of flux of hie of EHR
technology of changing healthcare
organization but that that would be a
good question to study yeah Dana some of
the hids are exploring value added
services like uploading reporting
responsibilities is that working what
did you learn about financial
sustainability of HIV as entities yeah
actually I think in that just left she
actually did that that part of the
report from what I know about this area
it you know like Indiana the Indiana hie
that's that they sustain themselves with
a number of you know kind of services
that they provide like for example the
the lab the freestanding labs that you
know they actually found it was actually
cheaper for them to deliver the results
electronically than to print it out on a
piece of paper stick it in an envelope
put on a stamp and mail it so early on
that actually funded a fair amount but
they're a big issue still remains with
the financial sustainability there some
of you who were around Portland maybe 10
years ago there was a in the pre
high-tech era there was this effort
to try to create an H metropolitan
Portland hie kind of modeled on places
like Indiana in New York and the whole
thing ultimate that there was a great
plan